können wir ewig leben und sind wir gar
nicht tot wenn wir tot sind
doch wie fühlte sich eigentlich an zu
sterben wann genau ist man tot und was
kommt danach
ihr habt euch genau das bei whatsapp
gewünscht wie ihr meine nummer whatsapp
hätten könnte dass er vater am ende des
videos und bekommt jetzt alle facts zu
diesem thema und alle details zum tod
herzlich willkommen bei diesem tödlichen
klicks um science-fiction video
ja für viele gilt der amerikanische soft
ihre lose als ein medizinisches wunder
2009 brach er zusammen sein herz stand
still und sein gehirn arbeitete nicht
mehr tirano sie war tot in einem der
besten krankenhäuser nordamerikas aber
gaben ärzte teams alles sie shoppen sein
herz mit 360 0 verpasst neben eine
herzdruckmassage und das immer wieder
zehn minuten später zeigte tirano sie
immer noch keine lebenszeichen doch die
ärztinnen und ärzten machen weiter
dabei lag hier eine grenze an der einige
andere teams die behandlung
wahrscheinlich schon abgebrochen hätten
tirano sie bekamen adrenalin gespritzt
doch auch nach 30 minuten zeigte er
keine reaktion
sollte das also doch alles umsonst
gewesen sein 40 minuten war der
chauffeur jetzt schon tot die meisten
ärzte teams hätten wohl jetzt spätestens
abgebrochen
denn das risiko ist groß dass weite
teile des gehirns abgestorben sind die
frage ist nämlich ob man es wirklich
schafft mit der beatmung genug
sauerstoff ins gehirn zu bekommen selbst
wenn das herz wieder zuschlagen beginnen
würde könnten die folgen fatal sei nach
47 minuten und 20 sekunden pcs laut die
null linie auf dem monitor geht über in
einen starken ausschlag nach oben und ja
der fall hat tatsächlich ein happy end
und was für eins der alu sie konnte das
krankenhaus nach drei wochen verlassen
zu fuß und genau genommen ist der kein
medizinisches wunder dafür aber ein
spektakulärer erfolg der modernen
reanimation medizin bis zu 30 prozent
des üblichen sauerstoffs kann das gehirn
durch eine gut ausgeführte liebt
wiederbelebung erhalten und das reicht
nur das problem das ist super
anstrengend selbst profis können dieses
niveau nicht länger als ein paar minuten
durchhalten aber aus meinem
bekanntenkreis da kenne ich einen fall
wo eine ältere frau mehrmals immer
wieder nur durch herzdruckmassage und
durch beatmung 30 minuten am leben
gehalten wurde und der körper mit
sauerstoff versorgt werden konnte so
dass die personen danach wieder
reanimiert werden konnte und diese
beatmung und herzdruckmassage hat eine
zierliche frau gemacht also es geht aber
herz lungen maschinen brustgurt und
hydraulische pumpen können das viel
besser außerdem enorm wichtig kälte die
den körper des verstorbenen
herunterkühlt
diagnose ist leben jedenfalls haben zum
einen die ausdauer der notfallmediziner
und zum anderen die kälte gerettet was
der fall von der musik deutlich zeigt
ist noch nicht allzu lange bekannt der
tod ist ein prozess und eben kein moment
er tritt langsam ein und breitet sich im
körper aussetzt stunden danach kann er
noch unterbrochen werden unter
bestimmten bedingungen natürlich noch
vor 60 jahren dachte man anders bum bum
bum und ende so lange eben wie das herz
schlägt leben wir wenn es aufhört sind
wir tot und das ist dann auch nicht mehr
rückgängig zu machen der österreichisch
amerikanische arzt peter seiffert damals
das buch abc situation indem er
erstmalig beschrieben hat wie man einen
menschen nach einem herzstillstand
wiederbeleben kann durch beatmen
freihalten der atemwege und
herzdruckmassage
doch was genau lässt uns nach 80 90 100
jahre mittlerweile manchmal sogar 120
jahren auf natürliche art und weise
sterben
da kann man nämlich dann nicht viel tun
in unserem körper sind millionen von
zellen und diese altern bisher daran
sterben unsere innere uhr tickt denn
irgendwann stoppt ein wichtiger
biologischer prozesse in unserem körper
die alltägliche zellteilung die dafür
sorgt dass alte zellen ausgetauscht
werden und ersetzt werden die alten
zellen sterben ab und leben nur noch in
einer art stand by modus der körperliche
verfall im alter beruht aber auch noch
auf anderen mechanismen am ende fallen
dann mehrere organe und biologische
prozesse aus die lunge das gehirn oder
das herz-kreislauf-system werden
manchmal auch als eintrittspforten des
todes bezeichnet medizinisch gesehen
gibt es auch nicht den tod zum einen
gibt es den so genannten klinischen tod
wenn das herz kreislaufsystem stockt und
organe nicht mehr versorgt werden
manchmal kamen dem noch mit
beatmungsmaschine neben oder einer
herzdruckmassage entgegengewirkt werden
beim irreversiblen hirntod sieht das
ganz anders aus laut der definition in
deutschland bedeutet das den ausfall des
groß und klein hirns und des hirnstamms
das bewusstsein geht damit verloren und
zwar unumkehrbar übrigens können selbst
in diesem zustand noch in sehr tiefen
schichten mancher hirnregionen
gehirnzellen aktiv seien maschinen
können manche funktionen eines hirntoten
körpers in gang hält
er kann seine eigene körpertemperatur
regulieren und manche hirntote frauen
haben sogar noch ihr baby bis zur geburt
ausgetragen in operationen reagieren
manche hirntoten patienten auf reize der
blutdruck steigt an und muskeln bewegen
sich medizinisch gesehen sind dafür
reflexe des rückenmarks verantwortlich
und nicht das empfinden von schmerzen um
die diagnose des hirn todes zu stellen
gibt es ganz klare richtlinien die zwei
ärzte unabhängig voneinander durch zu
gehen haben ihr habt sich ja auch schon
mal von nahtoderfahrungen gehört das
netzwerk nahtod erfahrung schätzt dass
etwa vier millionen menschen in
deutschland schon mal so ein mysteriöses
erlebnis hinter sich gebracht haben
beispielsweise nach einem unfall in den
berichten heißt es dann so etwas wie es
fühlt sich einfach an wie ein perfekter
schlaf aber ohne träume andere berichten
davon dass sie es eher wie ein leben
nach dem tod empfunden haben
beispielsweise von anderlecht vision am
ende des tunnels oder als eine art
lebens film manchmal sind es schöne
gefühle aber oft spielen auch angst und
panik eine rolle medizinisch gesehen
treten solche nahtoderfahrungen zwischen
dem klinischen tod und der reanimation
auf studien zufolge berichten etwa ein
viertel der patientinnen und patienten
die einen klinischen tod durchgemacht
haben von nahtoderfahrungen häufig vor
allem wenn die reanimation lange
gedauert hat oder besonders schwer war
neurologisch gesehen ist der nato quasi
ein ausdruck einer funktion stören
gehirn wenn eben die versorgung über
längere zeit nicht gut war
der bereich der rechtsmedizin der weiß
detailliert über die verschiedenen
phasen des todes bescheid fest steht
dass die organe oft noch eine zeit ohne
sauerstoff und nährstoffe klarkommen die
zellen im gehirn sterben nach etwa fünf
minuten das herz hält bis zu 30 minuten
aus dann sterben auch die zellen in
leber und lunge das blut sinkt ab weil
es nicht mehr zu gold todes flecken
entstehen und das kennt er aus krimis
die piraten ziemlich viel zum beispiel
über die todesursache und den zeitpunkt
ähnlich wie die totenstarre die nach
etwa zwei stunden einsetzt konkret
versteifen sich die muskeln und sterben
ab nach einigen tagen löst sich die
starre wieder ein bis zwei tage nach dem
einsetzen des todes gibt dann auch der
magen darm trakt auf bakterien beginnen
mit der zersetzung des körpers noch
länger halten spermien durch und zwar
bis zu drei tage lang 30 jahre lang
dauert der komplette zersetzungsprozess
des menschlichen körpers danach ist
wirklich nichts mehr von uns übrig wie
genau sich die momente des sterbens
anfühlen das wiederum ist noch
weitgehend unerforscht wie sollte das
auch gehen schließlich ist noch keiner
der mir bekannten toten wieder
auferstanden doch es gibt tierversuche
dazu demnach versiegt die
gehirnaktivität während des
sterbeprozess nicht allmählich sondern
steigt noch einmal für kurze zeit
deutlich an
das hat beispielsweise ein
forschungsteam der university of
michigan 2013 berichtet bisher ging man
allerdings davon aus dass es diesen
vorgang beim menschen nicht gibt gibt es
aber nach neuesten erkenntnissen und
vielleicht ist er für die beschriebenen
nahtoderfahrung verantwortlich
jedenfalls durch diesen irrtum ist als
phänomen beim menschen noch gänzlich
unerforscht wie sieht das sterben in
zukunft ausschließlich tüfteln
forschungsteams weltweit daran uns
ewiges leben zu verschaffen und ja die
visionen der wissenschaft sind
gigantisch die mit ursela stiftung in
virginia will es in zukunft schaffen
dass menschen biologisch gesehen für
immer bei einem alter von 25 jahren
bleiben können 90-jährige sollen so
gesund bleiben die 40 jahre jüngere die
biotechnologie macht immer mehr
fortschritte in richtung ewiges leben
unterstützt durch viel geld der
pharmaindustrie das time magazin hatte
2013 gefragt kann google soll des kann
google den tod aufhalten vorher hatte
der digital konzern google nämlich seine
tochter kaliko gegründet um mit 1,5
milliarden dollar
eine antwort auf genau diese frage zu
finden die hälfte der finanzierung hatte
ein pharmaunternehmen dazu steuert auch
der silicon valley milliardär larry
ellison ist ein todes gegner und hofft
dass viel geld zu zahlreichen
wissenschaftlichen entdeckung führt die
dann in kombination mit besseren
heilmethoden unser leben verlängern
können bis das zur realität wird kann
aber auch jeder einzelne selbst dafür
sorgen die qualität seines eigenen
lebens zu verbessern
denn im besten fall erhöht dies auch die
lebensdauer forschungsteams weltweit
verweisen immer wieder darauf dass
meditation zb stress reduzieren kann und
viel stress beschleunigt die biologische
alterung das sagen
viele studien natürlich und sport
gesunde ernährung und so weiter und so
fort und wenn das dann trotzdem nicht
reicht auch im bereich der
notfallmedizin sind forschungsteams
weltweit optimistisch man geht davon aus
dass wir in 20 jahren etwa in der lage
sein werden menschen zu rennen
reanimieren die bereits seit 24 stunden
tot sind ein fall wie die alu sie wäre
dann nicht mehr die ausnahme sondern die
regel
was aber passiert nach dem tod gibt es
ein leben danach werden wir wieder
geboren was passiert mit der
menschlichen seele ist sie unsterblich
ihr wisst alle was die verschiedenen
religionen dazu meinen manchmal werden
als beweis dafür die nahtoderfahrung
benutzt der körper habe sich von der
seele gelöst oder die seele vom körper
und an der schwelle zum jenseits
gestanden darüber gibt es
wissenschaftlich gesehen aber absolut
keinen konsens es gibt durchaus auch
wissenschaftler wissenschaftlerin die an
solche szenarien glauben die meisten
expertinnen in diesem bereich aber
erklären nahtoderfahrung neurologisch
und so liefern diese erlebnisse
keinerlei hinweise auf ein leben nach
dem tod oft wird auch die quantenphysik
bei dieser diskussion ins spiel gebracht
kann sie die verbindung zwischen dem
physikalischen körper und der der
immateriellen seele schaffen oder
zerschlägt sie diese sogar letztendlich
ist die quantenphysik allerdings auch
nur eine theorie über das verhalten
physikalischer teilchen
meiner meinung nach ist es zweifelhaft
dass sie seriöse aussagen über eine
immaterielle seele treffen kann klingt
eher nach ziemlichen quatsch ja und so
bleibt es weiter eine glaubensfrage ob
es eine unsterbliche seele gibt oder
eben nicht die wissenschaft jedenfalls
kann diese frage nicht beantworten wenn
er als erstes neues zu diesem thema und
zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt
dann endet meine telefonnummer bei
whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor
allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über
mich in der redaktion von blick zum
mitmachen und mehr zum beispiel themen
vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen
teilnehmen und somit bestimmen was hier
bei pixum passiert der direkte draht zu
mir einfach hier draufklicken und
natürlich nicht das aber mit der
genau locker vergessen und hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
ewiges leben möglich ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran